[Musique]
madame monsieur gère la mine devait
faire de notre ville quand un nombre
important de jeunes mais également un
nombre important d'associations
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
avec mes collègues du conseil municipal
souhaitait adopter un dispositif le
dispositif pass jeune citoyen afin de
favoriser l'engagement des jeunes
génovéfains dans la vie de la cité
concrètement l'idée est simple en
contrepartie de leur passé pour
l'intérêt général soit au sein des
services municipaux soit au son d'une de
nos associations
chaque jeune engagés dans le dispositif
pourra bénéficier d'une bourse de 500
500 euros pour financer ses projets
d'autonomie pour financer une partie de
200 permis de conduire pour financer
également une partie de ses frais de
scolarité ou quoi tout autre projet
c'est un dispositif extrêmement
important qui je crois répondent aux
attentes fortes de nos jeunes de vouloir
s'engager dans la vie de la cité mais
qui permettra également à nos
associations de pouvoir proposer des
missions qui ont du sens en direction de
la jeunesse génome fn si vous êtes un
jeune génovéfains je vous invite à
contacter le service jeunesse qui venant
à toutes les modalités pour vous
inscrire dans le dispositif et pour
répondre à l'une des missions qui sera
proposé dans le cadre de ce pass jeunes
citoyens et si vous êtes un un bénévole
associatif un dirigeant associatif je
vous invite à contacter l'espace de vie
associative de façon à travailler
ensemble les missions qui seront
proposées aux jeunes et de la fin je
vous invite pour avoir plus
d'informations à cliquer sur le lien
qui va apparaître et de façon à pouvoir
vous renseigner les plus concrètement
possible
je crois que la philosophie de ce
dispositif correspond pleinement à
l'état d'esprit qu'à sainte geneviève
cet état d'esprit fait d'engagement et
d'attachement à notre collectivité et je
suis certain que vous serez extrêmement
nombreux à répond au dispositif pass
jeunes citoyens
[Musique]